florida's doing a similar thing saying
you can't discriminate against someone
you can't force them to do this
especially if they have religious
exemptions a judged in new in new york
just upheld religious exemptions for
health care workers so legal leads
right now this is being decided in the
high courts and a lot of people are
siding with you have a right not to
comply with this mandate that they're
trying to force on you and this is
something that's you know imperative
this is something that's important this
is something that provides people
liberties and freedoms that historically
throughout life they never really had
ever
and now uh they're finally given this
ability that's slowly being eradicated
slowly being taken away from them and
people are saying no this is just
absolutely ridiculous this is over the
top this is draconian this is
totalitarian and people trying to stand
up against it are not using that same
kind of force and energy uh they're
trying to stop a lot of that
intrusion into our personal lives
yeah we have the story from gothamist
actually courtside with new york
healthcare workers seeking religious
exemptions reject vaccine appeal by nyc
teachers they report that new york can't
stop hospital and nursing home workers
from seeking religious exemptions to the
state's covet 19 vaccine mandate a
federal judge ruled tuesday requiring
workers to get vaccinated without
allowing such exemptions conflicts with
long-standing federal protections for
religious beliefs judge david hurd of
the u.s district court of the northern
district of new york wrote in his
decision the policy requiring all
hospital nursing nursing home and home
care staff to get vaccinated against
covet was initially issued under cuomo
we get the point point is the law
already exists and it's clear you can't
do that it's not authoritarian when we
fought long and hard had elected
representatives vote on something that's
literally a constitutional republic
process
joe biden being like nah don't care
cuomo being like so what don't care
cuomo with the law on the book saying
you couldn't do this said i hereby
decree that's authoritarianism
yeah when you look at the implications
of both of these policies you clearly
see one where you have government agents
intruding into people's lives punishing
them taking something away uh and and
issuing fines
for not going through another hoop that
they literally made up uh that hoop is a
very important one it's it's a very big
one and it has a lot of big implications
because if the government could do this
people could argue based on health
policy they could also do it to obese
people and fat people because of the
same kind of health guidelines for the
greater good of everyone the governor
bloomberg wants to exactly centralized
government arguing for the greater good
of everyone it's it's literally the
recipe for disaster all throughout human
history and it's being repeated now by
individuals saying yeah you know
fighting back against it is is futile
it's bad as well it's not do you guys
think that vaccine mandates are
unconstitutional across the board
no
what's the instance where it's not so
there there have been certain there are
certain circumstances where
i think vaccines can be mandated but
what you need to understand is that
there's also a scale of acceptable risk
meaning if you've got an airborne ebola
with a 50 mortality rate you're not
gonna have to worry about anything
people are gonna be panicking and
begging to be a part of the vaccination
program but we're dealing with covid
which is serious and long covet is
serious and i i don't know the exact
percentages but you know we don't want
people to die at the same time the the
the rate for individuals healthy under
the age of 40 is substantially lower so
we're dealing with a nuanced political
circumstance that being said there there
are some times like in the military for
instance they've mandated tons of
vaccines the difference here with covet
is that it's new
and um you know i talked about this
quite a bit when you join the military
they you know when you're in basic
training they give you a whole bunch of
vaccines you can require certain
vaccines for travel for certain work
right so when i was traveling to like
venezuela in egypt yellow fever
vaccination is a requirement because it
was an insurance requirement and this is
different this is the company saying
we're not firing you we're just telling
you like if you want to be the guy who
gets to go to venezuela like yo you
gotta get you got a yellow fever shot
and so i did and i went to the doctor
and he gave me the shot and it was it
was i think the yellow fever one hurt no
what's the yellow favorite one i don't
know one of them goes in your skin it
sucks
that i understand subcutaneous but if
you're gonna say
a public accommodation buying a sandwich
with on on a street that you you
are obligated to pay for right we all
know how luke feels about taxation i
think it's just for me
it's just for employees no in new york
the mandates are you can't even go
inside italy yeah so that's the other
thing too let's okay let's let's talk
about employers first of all for for the
regular for a regular person it
shouldn't be a lot but let's talk about
health care workers seeking religious
exemptions you know these hospitals
receive public funding that's my
understanding right they're on public
streets so you're telling me i have to
pay for it and then you're banning me
from using it because of what i my
religion no we already have a law saying
you can't discriminate in the basis of
religion now there's reasonable
reasonable exemptions to that like if
you believe in sacrificing goats not let
you do it in public like in the middle
of the street and 50 ebola death then
damn your religion and take it anyway
see the the difference there is
when we're dealing with issues
of like
viruses that aren't all identical people
have different expectations for the
risks they're facing with kovid it is
clear that there's a large percentage of
people who don't believe the risk is it
warrants a sacrifice of such great loss
of freedoms when it came to the civil
war people are like abraham lincoln did
a good thing you know in in in stock and
fighting the war slavery he needed to be
ended there's a great moral injustice
and so people need i've talked about
this before that
we all are trying to figure out where
the line is and what we're willing to
accept when we take certain actions
when it comes to an airborne ebola like
people's insides are being liquefied
we're like yo
we gotta do something about this and if
you're looking at a 20 mortality rate
and a vaccine that has like a 0.01 risk
factor most people are going to be like
i'll take it
but when you're dealing with this
there's one report saying that the the
risk factor for some for for a ch a boy
under 18
uh there's one study that came out
saying the myocarditis was a greater was
a higher percentage risk than getting
covered itself some studies showing
eight times i i don't know if that's one
study is good enough to say definitively
that's why i tell people go talk to a
doctor and figure it out talk someone
who knows about it
yeah
right and get second opinions the point
is
when it comes to issues of what we're
willing to give up our freedoms for
there are some things i think most
people recognize if an alien invasion
happened man there's a really tough
question about what we need to do to
rally everyone together to survive
if it's like
you know
a series of crimes
and it's in one city why should the
people of new york mandate everyone in
the country lose their right to bear
arms because of the crimes in their city
and that's basically what's happening
i've had i think what's happening also
is that there's a segment of people that
are like hey kovid we look at the
numbers it doesn't look that that
dangerous is what people are making it
out to be so this seems like it's
unconstitutional you've gone too far but
then there's other people that won't
leave their house because they're afraid
for their life and so for for abbott to
tell everyone in texas you can't mandate
it even though they might feel like
afraid for their life
is where i was like well there's the
authoritarian flag i'm not saying he's
wrong i'm just saying
but i think you bring up a good point i
think i think regardless of whether or
not this is severe to the disease no one
should have to uh give up their freedom
for someone else's fear
and that means even if there is an
airborne ebola you can choose to go get
vaccinated for it and other people who
don't well then that's their issue i
suppose
and we should be operating on a more you
know liberty minded and personal
response we need personal responsibility
and liberty even in the face of
something like an airborne ebola look
man if there was an airborne ebola 50
mortality people's insides were
liquefying i would go to the mountains
like i'm not going to go anywhere you
think that'll help you escape those kind
of things if you ever watch the stand
you would know sure sure it's a movie
and in this instance the risk is there
we don't you know the people who are
over here with with covet people over 40
are higher risk people that are obese
so what do we do
do we just
we destroy everything i mean economies
in shambles people are going hungry
people around the world are starving
we're seeing massive ripple effects it's
affecting everything unless people want
a great reset i think at a certain point
you need to recognize that we need to
strip look ultimately i'll say it like
this you know what i i do not support
the vaccine mandates however
if there were a legislative body that
voted
and there were long-term uh uh studies
and then specific exemptions i'd be like
okay well it was done through an
electoral process having governors and
the president just declare by edict i'm
like no way
absolutely not when we talk about you
know vaccines like for mmr at schools
and stuff i'm like yeah but these are
vaccines that have been around
researched for decades they've been
around for even longer than that a lot
of these vaccines went through very
serious and rigorous studies over over
seriously 20 to 30 years now when it
comes to the the covet vaccine operation
warp speed it's the one of the fastest
projects ever done
i don't think personally
a lot of people think that there's like
you know the vaccine is dangerous i
don't i don't think that i think
ultimately my opinion is a relevance i'm
not a doctor i just think people's
medical choices are their own
if people have a sincere medical uh
religious belief like imagine if
imagine if de blasio said you have to
eat bacon
like everybody must eat bacon right now
like you'd have a whole lot of religious
people being up in arms like you can't
do that so there's a similar thing there
i'll tell you this though there it is a
fair point absolutely to say the lines
between what we're willing to accept are
different for everybody and there are
some people who are staunchly
libertarian and even if there was an
airborne zombie virus would be like you
cannot force me to do anything no matter
what and there would be other people who
were like seemingly libertarian before
now being like at this point lock
everyone in their houses
so i i think everybody has their line
how much risk you're willing to it is
it's on it's a gradient scale and to
make laws as a white or a black or a yes
or no or a one or a zero that's it's
that's tough however be a personal
decision but when it comes to what
abbott is saying like i thought about
this i've said this before i'm like i
don't like the idea that you know
desantis was like nobody can bet nobody
can mandate masks and i'm like let's
should go to the legislature right
however
you know masks are different from the
vaccine thing the mass thing i think is
interesting if somebody wants to require
a mask in their store like what's your
justification for saying they have they
can't require shirts or they can't they
have they can require shirts vaccines
different it's a it's an irreversible
medical procedure and there are people
with medical issues over the fetal cell
use and there are people with medical
issues with religious issues over the
fetal cell use and medical issues that
i take
i have religious problems with it
personally i i it violates everything i
hold dear to my my my spirit i
i will not touch it no i i would never i
would never in a million years feel
right taking a rushed vaccine
with the evidence i have and that is a
religion that is my true belief in what
i am
i so i mean i never defined my religion
but that's how so let's put this
conscience yeah do you think that you
have a right to public accommodation in
the comments no you don't think oh in
the commons
i mean yeah yeah my through my tax
dollars yeah right so do you think then
abbott saying guys this guy's paying
taxes you can't kick him out
is that is that authoritarianism
yeah
because if i start violating their
semblance of normality and then he's
like you still can't get rid of them but
this is this is something you pay for
with your taxes yeah for them to tell
you that you have no access to these
spaces would be them stealing from you i
guess i get access but it's up to me to
to maintain dignity to stay there like
if i pull my pants down then then right
so so then i i would say this the
question that i have about the vaccine
mandate is if they're going to say well
you have to have a vaccine mandate why
don't them come along and say okay a
vaccine
or a negative coveted test
and it's the lack of or a negative covet
test that knocks it out for me because
if you said or a negative cova test that
would mean that the
mandate was really about
coven the fact that there's no
or a negative covid test means they're
just wanting everyone to be vaccinated
come hell or high water
so again this leaves us in the absurd
scenario where someone who has covid
but is vaccinated can go into a
restaurant and
breathe as much as they want and someone
who can prove that they don't have kovid
is kicked out right that's the absurdity
that that the vax mandates and the vax
passport that's what that's what gets me
if you can say
or i mean where i live it's
of you have to show vax proof of
vaccination or a negative cova test and
the antigen cova tests are going for
like 200 bucks a pop people people want
them but that you can do that you can
say still it's still
there's still a problem there in that
man what they're mandating at some
universities like every three days
who's got the time no to go and do that
and spend that money so then people just
go fine screw it i'll do whatever you
say and that's and that's the problem so
that that's a good a good moral
conundrum though the ebola thing like
what everyone's rights are be damned if
this if the virus is severe enough
perhaps and then the issue is you're
right how the democrats are terrified
they're shaking and then they really are
we look at the polls look look what
happened when we invited uh hassan [ __ ]
on the show and he was like i'm totally
down i'll do it and then he was like yo
i'm kind of worried about kofit we have
people here all the time who are kind of
like we wash our hands we use hand
sanitizer we take precautions we clean
everything you know and and we we we're
actually i think we're actually socially
distanced right now we are yeah we're
probably
socially distant at this table and uh
but we we have to live our lives man so
uh no disrespect to hassan he's
genuinely concerned about this but his
concern is is several orders of
magnitude more than ours
you know what i mean
so then if if he's going to vote for
what he wants lockdowns and we're going
to refuse that
i don't know and maybe the real simple
solution is if you're scared you stay
home you know the beauty of the united
states is that each state is uh is an
experiment and this is an opportunity to
watch it happen in texas and see if that
if i maybe maybe i'm in this side
misusing authoritarianism i know it's
not an extreme authoritative thing what
he did but this is an opportunity to see
if what he's doing works i mean the
experiment was there in sweden it was
there in florida it was there in many
places around the world that said we're
not going to be playing ball there's a
lot of other experiments right now
happening in places like norway just
released a lot of their restrictions
their lockdowns their mandates masks all
of that their case numbers went down so
uh there's so many examples of of of
experiments i always said from the
beginning of this sweden's going to be
the true test of this because if you
remember they were saying that sweden's
going to end up in a bloodbath there's
going to be bodies stacking on top of
bodies there's going to be a massacre of
unprecedented proportions everyone's
going to die in sweden because somehow
sweden's not following along with the
programming they're not going along what
they're told to do by the by the world
economic forum by the world health
organization by a lot of these quote
experts and look what happened to sweden
look at their numbers compare their
numbers to the states that lock down the
most compare their numbers to israel and
singapore and you will truly have your
eyes opened why
wide by the disparity of numbers thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time